[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kim is
with us Kim is in Asheville North
Carolina starting off this hour hi Kim
how are you hello how are you better
than I deserve what's
up okay so I have a question um we hired
a gentleman to do our taxes in March of
this year and we ended up hiring him to
do financial planning for us as well and
after hiring him to do that we
discovered that he had filed bankruptcy
twice and had been sued for writing a
bad
check and so my question is um well he
fil bankruptcy in 2019 was his last one
that was the second one and the it said
the certified financial planning board
revoked his right to use their
certification marks H and then he also
was sued for writing a bad check to a
moving company recently and
that was um in
2018 and
so we had already paid him a large fee
to use him for financial planning and I
guess my question is should this be of
concern to
us we have discussed this with him what
did he say he says that we don't
understand what it's like to run our own
business
um and just basically was you know he
was very rude about it and said his
business would go on with or without us
o uh I want my money back I am leaving I
don't care about the bankruptcy with
your butt I don't want to work with
you right and he you don't get to be
rude to me about this you're s you're
self you're defensive which means that
yeah I've been I've been sued and I
filed bankruptcy but if you ask me about
it I'll just tell you I almost feel like
you not last week but I mean I'll just
tell you right I almost feel like you
open with that if you're if that's part
of your story that's what informed you
to this point he claimed that he told us
in the contract well I made him send
that back to us because it disappeared
after we signed it and we couldn't see
our own copy so he sent it to me a
couple weeks ago there was a link that
we could click in small print about this
how much did you pay this guy
$1,500 okay will he refund you or not he
will not okay I'm walking anyway walking
anyway I'm walking anyway
well yeah we told him we were walking
because we don't trust him and just
because of his attitude exactly exactly
it's not the thing it's the attitude
okay because here's the thing okay let's
say the moving company tore up 17 of his
items and then they would then they
wanted to you know and then he unpacked
it and found a vase that they were
responsible for they don't want to
refund him for the broken vase so he
stops payment on the check they sue him
well that's a valid story sure right he
also he told me that he did didn't he
settled that check I said well you
didn't settle it or they wouldn't have
sued you yeah and well it's the attitude
is the thing it's like look hey if I
were in your here's the proper way to
answer this question if I'm him if I
were in your shoes I'd have these exact
same concerns I'm happy to tell you the
details okay here's what happened in
this situation and here's what happened
in that situation and the bankruptcy was
not you don't understand why it's like
to run a business the bankruptcy was I
did some stupid butt things I learned
from it and I'm not doing them anymore
the check was the moving company
misbehave and I used that as leverage
and it got out of hand and they sued me
but they had no basis to judge through
it out yeah he blamed his ex-wife for
the bad check I I don't care you see
what I'm saying that if you had gone
that way then he would have redeemed his
credibility if he had been smarter and
done what Jade said and set up front
what was going on it's part of your
story that's fine that's fine that's
what we felt but i' I've been sued for
things that I didn't do that they made
up in an effort to try to basically use
the court system to Blackmail me to
settle with them I refuse to settle with
them so that gets all in the news so you
can look up Dave Ramsey got sued but the
basis of the lawsuits are zero didn't
absolutely did not occur but it doesn't
matter you can sue somebody for anything
in America so I don't mind telling you
that that's happened okay um but but
I've still got you know I've still got
if you want to be pissed at Dave Ramsey
randomly you can find places on the
internet that I did all kinds of things
I didn't
do yeah well I you know he said he was
going to sue the certified financial
planning board for good luck with that
yeah and I was like how can you do that
yeah he just sounds a little I don't I
really don't like his attitude I don't
like that he's defensive he sounds like
he's pointing the finger blaming it
doesn't sound like it's going to be a
fun work environment for you to work
with this I'm walking away I think I
think I think you should walk away and
you already had walked away so you
already knew the answer to the question
yeah she well she probably wanted to
know if there was some way she could
force him to get the money back but I
wouldn't put any e into it i' just move
on I don't think you're going to turn
him into not being a jerk yeah I think
he's already got that one down well if
he hasn't done any work for them yet in
that capacity I feel like a good person
would say hey you didn't know this
haven't started this yet here's your
money even a not good person knows that
some customers are worth more are more
trouble than they're worth and if I'm
her and I disagree with her I mean if
I'm him and I disagree with her she's
more trouble than she's worth here's
your money back yeah go away even if
even even if I'm not a good person it's
just it's worth the just to get rid of
them absolutely you know we fire a
customer around here that misbehaves
ever so often they you can't call here
and cuss at our people we don't allow
you to do that yeah we'll give you your
money back tell you go away you know
that's all right I don't I don't put up
with your junk cuz some customer service
uh people in America their whole job is
to get cussed at by Rah holic all day
long ter and we don't our our customer
service people I tell them listen just
tell them no yeah we don't wait a minute
wait we don't talk like that here you
doing that just call somewhere else and
be pissed off take your money and that
you're going to use here and use it for
counseling you need it you know that
just move on right but yeah I mean it
it's even if you're on the other side of
it it's worth it to get rid of and I
don't think Kim's that I think Kim's
figured this out um yeah the sad thing
is is that now she's questioning all
Financial people or planners yeah
whether trustworthy I'll tell you what
you know smartvestor Pro will sit down
with you they don't charge you a thing
because they make a commission yep off
of uh you a mutual fund for your for
your Roth IRA or your kids college fund
um and they don't make anything unless
they sell you something so people are
all suspect about that but they're the
good ones they do it with the heart of a
teacher that's why we endorse smart
Vestor Pros uh we don't have any fee
based financial planners in our system
yeah that are upfront
fees uh not because I'm mad at them they
just don't like
us because I endorse mutual funds yeah
that makesense and um you
know because here's the thing there's a
thing in the financial world is worth
talking about this in the 20 seconds
we've got called the fiduciary and you
see it on there's there's one company
running and they're lying about it on
their TV ad during uh football I saw it
last two or three weekends I can't think
what it's called little green sign in
the background but like where are
fiduciaries we are fiduciaries we don't
make anything unless you make something
we are fidu no the word fiduciary means
a person of
trust can you trust someone that gets a
commission yes if they're
trustworthy all real estate agents are
commission-based fiduciaries and they
should put your interest first yeah they
just they but just because you get paid
when they make a sale doesn't mean you
can't have integrity that's right that's
absurd so that's the financial world
right now